one your live chat
thank you
good evening and welcome to this
performance governance and audit
committee meeting on march 24th of march
2022 my name is councillor jeanette
stiltz and i am the chair of this
committee
members the set up for this for the
meeting has been designate designed to
mitigate for covid
therefore can i ask all present to work
to the protocol
coles agreed at council on 2nd september
2021
in the interests of member and officer
safety we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in the meeting you are giving
your sen consent to being recorded
members and officers during each item
please put your hand up to indicate if
you wish to speak and i will invite you
to speak at the appropriate time
please note that the youtube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of microphones therefore
can i ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn your microphone on
and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible
members in the addition to the offices
in the chamber we have offices attending
remotely
finally can i draw your attention to the
notices on the agenda regarding the
different levels within the chamber and
advise that the fire exit is the door
behind this table top
i'd also like to welcome councillor
morgan our new councillor to this
committee tonight
apologies for absence berna do we have
any apologies for absence
and thank you chairman yes we received
apologies for absence from councillors
hull and heard and councillor morgan is
in attendance as a substitute for
councillor hall with council sean c
substituting for our councilor heard
thank you thank you ben
item three on the agenda it's
recommended that the minutes held on the
10th of february 2022 found on pages
five to eight are approved as a true and
accurate record
i so do move do i have a seconder
thank you councillor keys
are there any questions from any members
on those minutes
are you all happy to accept those
minutes
thank you
item for declaration of interest to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 6 to 8
inclusive the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should they need a rise throughout the
meeting
do i have any declarations of incident
councillor stamp
um yes thank you chair and i'd like to
declare a non-pecuniary interest as a
member of kessick's county council on
any agenda items pertaining pertaining
to that organisation thank you
councillor
fleming
thank you chair a non-pecuniary as a
member of essex county council any
matter that pertaining thank you
thank you
item five on the agenda is public
participation
we have received a
a question from mr fitock
and it has been answered by an email so
his question has been answered
sorry i've lost my place
item six on the agenda
yes council stamp thank you would you
mind if i just asked for public
participation would it not be advisable
that um or if it's allowed in the
constitution so i'll look to councillor
boyce if it is um that it's actually
read out and the answers read out
because sometimes the public questions
are very informative not only to the
members of the public but to members of
this council
so i'm not sure if that's allowed or not
allowed i did ask the officers if this
question should be read out because it
is quite a long question with quite long
answer
i will go to mr dobson
yes thank you chair it was my
understanding that this was a question
to the chairman that was addressed to
you as chairman that wasn't
submitted as a formal public question
for the committee so it was answered
outside of the
the the public participation protocols
okay thank you
councillor boyce um chairman uh that
actually raises um an issue that perhaps
that our constitution is silent on
public participation has always meant
the the public being present
so do we need
in view of what council of stamp has
just suggested do we need to look at the
constitution to see if written questions
would be allowed
at some time in the future
mr
dobson
yes i think
written questions
could be allowed and i think probably
under the the changes we made
um
to the constitution could have been
it wasn't submitted in that that manner
as a public participation question that
that that was the point
uh no chairman i i i take mr dodson's um
uh answer uh
i was just raising for the future not
for the from uh
from the past the only caveat perhaps to
having questions
running it through my mind very quickly
is at the moment it's anybody that turns
up 20 minutes before
and there's a length of time which
these public questions are answered
if we open it up to
written questions
um
they might become out of control so it
does need some
thought
thank you
council stamp
i'm sorry thank you i see council fuku's
got his hand up but yeah i'd just like
to come back the reason i raised it was
because the chairman said public
participation actually on that point
so um so i wasn't being difficult it was
just i think it's really important that
we are we are our residents are heard
and especially with the subject matter
that um the email was about i think it
could be beneficial like i said to
members as well as residents thank you
mr hayes
i'd be happy to circulate the answer
that went in the question and the answer
went out to all members in the committee
so that they can see it
okay
um thank you chairman um i just wondered
why miss dotson's actually looking at
this whether or not we should look at
agenda five as well because it doesn't
you know it's a little bit cumbersome
the way it's written and i think that we
might need to just take a little look at
that as well because it does say on
there that you can complete your
question online but it's a bit late
after the agenda's been published so
perhaps you might like to look at the
word
yeah
maybe that's something
yes
councillor fleming did you want to sign
some new science okay
the question is there and and
if people want to see it i'm quite happy
to have it circulated with the answer
that would come from um
miss and uh
halt shortland
item six on the agenda is the update on
the audit of the 2021 accounts found on
page 9 to 12
to consider the report from the director
of resources mr leslie i'll hand over to
you
thank you chair
this report updates the committee on the
progress of the audit at the start of
the year just 40 percent of local
government body audits had been
completed nationally
as previously reported this is due to a
variety of factors including a national
star shortage covered and increased
audit requirements section 5 of the
report provides a recap of some of the
challenges
audit of the council's accounts
commenced again in january with progress
being made and no significant issues
raised to date
work is aimed to be completed in april
however
international and national issues could
cause a further delay in signing of the
accounts the impact of the pension fund
assets due to the ukraine war is being
considered by auditors in addition an
accounting issue has been raised
nationally around infrastructure assets
and changes to the accounting guidance
are due to be issued in due course to
rectify this which auditors will need to
wait for
neither of these will impact on the
council's general fund position that has
been reported in the accounts however
preparation for this year's accounts has
not been delayed and the auditors were
able to conduct their interim audit in
february as planned
thank you
uh recommendation is that the report be
considered do i have a seconder for that
recommendation
councillor fleming um members are there
any questions that you would like to ask
mr leslie
councillor stamp um yes thank you
if you could just refresh our memories
because i can't remember if it's 2019
maybe it was before your time or just
when you started when we got the new
auditors in and so i'd look to
councillor fluker and councillor boyce
for some guidance on this as well
in in the fact that they new auditors
came in and those accounts were delayed
because of a discrepancy under assets
so has that
because i think we negotiated prices as
well didn't we we have to renegotiate
the fees that were being paid to the
auditor at the time the new auditors
so why is it why is it now suddenly a
national issue
when it was an issue to this council
before so if you could just explain to
me what the changes are from central
government now that's affecting us and
affecting our audit
thank you madam chair thank you thank
you so um changes around the accountancy
guidance
that we're talking about uh is not
something from national government it's
actually done by the charter institute
of public finance and accountancy within
their accounting guidance
it actually relates to a technical
accounting issue
with the guidance which has been worded
as such for a
number of years however
auditors have
raised concerns this year
around it and have met as a group of
auditors to consider this technical
issue
they have raised it with cypher the body
who are then reviewing that
in light of the auditor's comments and
they're going to make some changes so
that the auditors are comfortable now to
sign off the account largely it will
affect those highway authorities with um
those sort of infrastructure assets the
roads etc
around that
um it does date back to
a while ago when the
valuation reserves were first created at
the time and the estimates around that i
believe uh in the 90s around that so
it's just something that's been raised
this year by external auditors even
though perhaps it was present for a vast
number of years previously
i can say that that's not just us that's
going to be every council that will be
this will affect councillor stamp yeah
thank you but mine was specifically what
happened a few years ago
because the i just remember everybody
renegotiating the price it was highly it
was a lot of money and the reasons given
at the council was because it was a new
auditor that had to get used to
different systems or something something
like that i can't remember exactly
i was just hoping that you know we're
not going to be charged a lot more money
again because of delays which are not
hopefully this council's fault
thank you
is there any other questions from mr
leslie
no
are members happy to uh
consider
that report
knighted thank you
item seven on the agenda is the repeat
review of the corporate performance
quarter three found on pages 13 to 40.
miss hughes would you like to present
your report
good evening members
this report covers the third quarter of
21-22 september to december 21 for
performance against our corporate plan
delivery
section 3.3 of the covering report gives
a broad update for each theme and
highlights the position as of quarter 3
along with any areas of concern
you will see for all three themes
delivery is broadly on track as of
quarter three but there are conditional
elements
the detail behind this is then set out
in appendix a from page 19 onwards of
your agenda pack
some of the measures themselves or the
way they are being delivered is under
review and text to give the explanation
around this is available in each
individual area
section 3.4 of the report then draws out
the specific indicators that sit at
these scene levels as theme levels that
are at risk
currently one indicator has met this
criteria which is the five-year housing
land supply statement which is sitting
in place strategy
page 22 of your agenda pack includes
further detail about this particular
measure
any development in performance since
january will then be reflected in our
next quarter 4 report
members are invited to review and
feedback on the corporate performance
report and confirm assurance of
effective performance management thank
you
thank you miss hughes so the
recommendations is little one that
members review the information as set
out in this report an appendix one with
priority focus given to the strategic
outcome level performance
and little two that members confirm that
they are assured through this review
that core performance is being managed
effectively
do i have a seconder for those
recommendations
councillor fleming thank you do i have
any questions from miss years
stevens
thank you chair
starting on page 13 um at the very
bottom of page 13 where it talks about
place
it says there are some conditional
elements identified that are in office
of focus to enable some outcomes to
continue to deliver on target
and that that expression is used over
and again and i'm slightly struggling to
understand
what that means i read it a few times
and i think i got there but as a general
point i
as a new member i am still finding these
documents are way harder to read than
they need to be by the deadline i'm not
criticizing the quality of the documents
it's just so hard to read and i don't
think they need to be i ran one of
tonight's reports
through a flesh reading ease software
and it scored just 25 which means very
difficult to read best understood by
university graduates
so i'm happy with the compliment
but
they just don't need to be quite so
difficult to read and if somebody could
just take
five minutes to run each finished piece
of work through that software which is
in word
and maybe just take advice from
mr gates and change a few things
i think we'd all finish reading these
documents before the meeting thank you
thank you
mr dobson would you like to come back
yes um
quite timely really because we are
reviewing the format of the reports and
um
we will be looking to to undertake a
workshop with members both to look at
the format of how some of these reports
look um but also how we present them
that we'll be be looking to to go
through in april so that'll be an
opportunity for us to simplify them
hopefully and make them more
understandable because that's that is
the point of them
and counselor stamp i'll come back to
your counselor stevenson counsellor
if next cancer seems to want some
follow-up i'll wait okay
was that a follow-up question councillor
stephen no i've just got a list of
questions so okay feel free
um yeah thank you i actually did write
on the the top of that page what and
another one what does it mean um because
i i also struggled to understand um some
of it um madam chair i don't know if
it's the appropriate time but i've just
highlighted where it says
fly tipping incidents i've just put
bulky items still suspended costa
council reputation service delivery
i think because the previous meeting we
had i was told this was the one to
review performance review and correct me
if i'm wrong because i'm new to this
committee
um but
um fly tipping comes up again i think
further on when when you look at all the
lovely diagrams and graphs and
everything that comes out of this and it
says here
total fly tip removals 21 354 pounds now
is that further broken down is there any
evidence where they are are they
habitual offenders is it you know it
just
no don't write to me but um fly tipping
incidents it means nothing so have we
got the drill down the information that
that can back that up please i did ask
that question on that did you get an
answer before i did that so i asked it
went the agenda meeting so there should
be an answer mr holmes
i can give you i can give an overview um
so obviously fly tipping can be from
very minor to quite large
and our officers do investigate
where they can find the evidence to take
board obviously people sometimes slip
they put identifier materials in there
and in those cases we're able to take
action but we are working with our um
contractor to be
working a bit smarter about the way we
deal with fly tips to make sure we can
capture as much data as we can so we can
improve that sort of ability to go back
and chase um
we talk about a global figure um
obviously depending what it is depending
on the material it can obviously vastly
difference between the cost of a small
removal or asbestos so it does vary um i
haven't got sort of specific numbers of
instances we could break that down a
little bit further and so was that 10 or
15 or 100 so we could we could look at
that for you but um we met with our
street scene collector contractor um a
month or so ago um had a sort of general
discussion how we might work better with
our enforcement team to try and trying
to sort of follow through in more cases
if we can but um yeah that's that's the
situation at the moment councillors
don't you want to come back i do really
because i think we all know in our wards
that we have an area where you always
see it it gets cleared and then six days
later or you know ten days later it it's
actually something
else is there but i'd like the bulky
item this is this our
delivery that's still suspended i mean
you only have to look where was it down
the marshes there was a city the other
day and then you've got people all over
facebook saying who can i get to remove
my bed how can i get my sofa rid of
and then you find it on the back of a
truck going down midnight down creeks
elaine or somewhere and you see it when
you take your dog for a walk so when
away when are we as a council gonna be
able to resume that service because it
was very handy that the council would
come and pick it up and dispose of it
and and is there a correlation between
the evidence of fly tipping being
greater now since the suspension of the
bulky items you might not be able to
answer it because you maybe haven't got
that that level of scrutiny but you know
we that's the sort of thing we need to
be looking at i think if we have got the
manpower which i understand maybe we
don't thank you because uh mr holmes
yes i'll be i'll be happy to get a view
from our our team in terms of whether
they believe there is a correlation or
things that are turning up could be
account as a result of not having the
bulky waste collections and as far as
the bulky waste collections are it's
actually just a resourcing issue with
the contractor and they are as you
probably know are struggling um drivers
and loaders are dealing with cobit at
the moment so that was the service that
took um you know we suspended that
service to make sure we could focus on
the normal collections
it's not getting any easier for
contractor particularly at the moment
we've covered as you know some of the
greenway services have had to be
suspended for the last two weeks and
that's simply because driver shortages
so
in the short term i don't think we'll be
able to reinstate that but i will um
update that position with the contractor
and i'm happy to put a note back to the
committee on that thank you mr holmes
mr boyce uh councillor boyce sorry i'm
quite happy as i've explained to you
before chairman mister is quite happy
with that in fact call me anything as
long as it's not late for breakfast
um now i've forgotten what i was going
to say
um
chairman um
i seem to remember that at one time we
had some involvement with the
environment agency with cctv
cameras being put at
some preferred
dumping sites is that still happening
have we got a covert
uh
capability i will go back to mr holmes
i don't believe we've got any uh current
at the moment i think it has to be very
specific about a site a problem site
where you can actually uh where we get
the repeated drops so i think in those
instances it would happen but i might
ask mr keeley just to add to that if you
can
thank you
yes just to confirm um with some of the
cases that i've come across here um
the environment agency are involved when
it when it hits certain
top topics and targets and
certain
themes emerging certain behaviors are
noticed and then they'll put in extra
resources that can include the use of
cctv but if it doesn't hit any of those
triggers um then it's really just down
to our own resourcing and what we can do
to track down flight rippers in
conjunction with the contractor
thank you um
yeah thank you i'm sort of surprised by
that answer in some ways because i think
everybody knew what happened at webworld
leisure plots
and i understand now that the the
absentee owners of the plot the
environment agency are actually pursuing
them for 21 million pounds to clear the
site up even though the environment
agency were acutely aware of who was
tipping the waste in there
um
so
what begs the question is
everybody knew what was going on and
then you're nodding
so why didn't they have any cctv and why
has nobody been prosecuted for this
that question the environment agency
would would have to answer and i could
certainly ask those questions from my
contacts over there but in terms of our
own resources
yes we've got certain types of
intelligence
that can include people who we suspect
in terms of our own resources
i don't believe we've got any cctv
equipment that we can deploy
it's a case of officers going down there
and noticing things themselves with the
resources and the tools that we've got
just come back i'm even more confused
now because i was working with mr
and he actually provided
covert cameras
for my ward and signs
so
clearly something's
happened since then if we're not
actually doing that
and it is a problem but
kevin my question on this really and i'm
sure mr gator will come back to me on
that later the other day but to really
understand this we need to understand
what's been going on
last year and how these figures are
changing
um you know we
you've now got the situation in
malden
where you can only go into more than now
with the van or commercial vehicle if
you book in advance
and the reason why we track these
figures i ask these figures to be
tracked was when the civic community
site in burnham came from sort of seven
or six days a week down to three and we
tracked it and we did see a peak but
that seems to have gone down but i think
to understand to understand these
figures we need to be able to compare it
you know to uh
to perhaps last year to see where we are
but my other question actually wasn't
anything to do with this so i'll just
wait until we go through the pack a bit
yeah
i'll get an answer to those resources
i'll come back to you
miss hughes there was question in there
from
uh councillor fluka
about the
looking at the figures of last year
compared to this year did you want to
come back on that
so we do look at fighting in data as
part of the operational reporting in the
balanced scorecard
and obviously we would report if
[Music]
did you want to come back before thank
you councillor stevens you
thank you yes i have a few more
questions please um at the top of page
14 it refers and this is back to fly
tipping but a different aspect of it it
says fly tipping incident data has gone
through a data cleanse due to a change
of data source for more accurate
reporting does that mean we have a new
database or somebody else is giving us
the data or what does that mean please
thank you
mr geller
i
don't know anything about that i'll
check that out and get back to you
councillor stevens carry on
bit further down that page 14 we've got
section 3.4 where it says the following
indicators has have been annotated as at
risk for quarter three so the first one
there place
um it's talking about the five-year
housing land supply
is it
is the place risk here that the
statement will be published late or does
it mean
we're at risk of not having a five year
supply i mean clearly the second is true
but is the is it also at risk of being
late
mr dobson it relates directly to the the
supply itself the it won't be late in
reporting okay thank you and the other
two there the prosperity and community
risks are both shown to be at risk as
well but it doesn't say what the risk is
mr dobson or misuse
sorry
what which page
we're going to do page 14
section 3.4 we've got place prosperity
and community
strategies all showing us at risk but
there are no comments about the
prosperity and community so i'd like to
understand what
sorry the at-risk relates to individual
indicators within that so there are none
that are at risk within those areas is
what it's saying
okay thank you i wouldn't have read it
like that so it says at risk none it
means there is no risk
okay
thank you
is there any other questions
councillor stevens
sorry i'm trying to keep up with my
cursor here or it's trying to keep up
with me the next one's page 19.
i'm just scrolling down
um stop me if i've gone beyond the end
of the report that i'm meant to be
talking about um
it's a sense thing again um yeah play
page 19 we've got a table there
corporate plan reference three deliver
the housing the district needs
i don't think i understand that it says
growing concerns of the five-year
housing land supply falling below three
years is viewed as almost inevitable if
significant progress isn't seen by end
of year along with the housing
trajectory kpi also under review due to
the progression of the ldp review now
superseding
something
i don't really understand what what
that's saying
mr dawson or misuse
my understanding is it's because the the
review of the ldp has superseded the
figures that were used in preparing that
that data
okay thank you
so moving on to page 22
um
we've got a column on page 22 for target
but not seeing but we're not seeing any
actuals there so taking the second
column sorry the second row down as an
example
um the number of affordable homes
delivered it says it's on track and that
we need to deliver 130 a year but
there's only about a dozen described
there so
i think having as well as the target the
actual numbers would be useful to prove
that it's on track really
would that be possible please
misuse
so for some of those measures we only
get annual data
the officers marked it as on track um
based on their knowledge of uh what's
going on
and that's why they provide the summary
sort of highlights and low lights uh
information um but actually the data
wouldn't always update
other than annually for some of those
measures
in that case how are we able to give the
q3 figures there
presumably if we've got q3 figures
listed here we must have q1 and q2 as
well i'd have thought
sorry
so
sorry i'm perhaps really being a bit
stupid because i'd have thought if here
we're saying that there have been four
two bedroomed houses and four three
bedroom houses etc that adds up to about
10 or 12 houses or whatever in the third
quarter so if we've got those numbers
for the third quarter we must also have
similar numbers hopefully bigger numbers
for the second and first quarters if
we're on track to deliver 130
this year
i can't see how we're on track to
deliver 130 if we've only delivered 12
in a quarter
mr dobson did you want to come back yes
my understanding is
we have some housing delivery numbers
and we have some completion numbers
the figures that are reported
annually after a survey and a collection
of all of the the data at the end of the
year
so the the information that's shown here
isn't the full data set
for the quarter
what they will do is collate all of the
information at the end of the year when
it is fully reported so that's why there
isn't a hard and fast progress towards
this in quarter one two and three
because it's incomplete data they only
have a complete data set at the end of
the year when they do all of the surveys
all of the checks and do the full report
so it's it's not fully reported
quarterly is my understanding
councillor stevens can thank you i mean
it just seems strange that somebody can
calculate therefore that it is on track
but can't show us that it is on track i
think that's
what i'm seeing written here doesn't
seem to illustrate the the green on
track
status so it just leaves me with a
slightly worried feeling connect that
one can i go to councillor stamp who put
her hand up because i think she's got a
question on this
thank you madam chair yes i have i think
this is a really interesting point
especially when you if members know i've
raised a query under viewing scrutiny um
because it concerns me about the
tracking and why we've not been able to
identify before we've got in the pickle
we find ourselves in at the moment with
the ldp and i think cancer stevens is
ready to raise an excellent point
because we don't continually check and
monitor
annually it's no good it's we're not you
know if you've got to the end of the
year and we're supposed to deliver 130
homes and we're only on 20 you've got no
chance of actually the council adjusting
on putting some measures in to reach
that and i've actually put similar
points to what you've raised councillor
stevens as well but i'd like to if you
don't mind cuz i'm i've put on the one
above where there is an at-risk it says
here the five-year land supply is still
falling at last quarter there is a risk
that it may slip under three years by
april that's not as may anymore it's
going to happen unless the council
approves significant amount of housing
which will be deliverable delivered
within five years this is unlikely to
happen given many refusals of
permissions that have already taken
place and i've just put what in big
letters strategic sites what the the
information is not
what i would call drill down or enough
that anybody can
it's alright producing a risk register
if we can't do anything that
is
behind the risk if that makes sense now
officers may have that information but
when we're sitting here to try and
debate it and understand it i personally
feel that we should know more about it
and i'm sorry to give anybody a hard
time but i'd like to understand it as
well because that's why i've raised it
at ons because i think it's really
important that we know what on earth is
going on thank you mr dobson's dying to
answer those questions
thank you sharon i'll actually bring um
ann out off shoreland in a moment but i
i wanted to go back to one of the things
council stamps said around
the delivery of houses
referring to the the previous point from
councillor stevens around the the
affordable houses
we've passed the housing delivery test
for the last four years the five-year
housing land supply and the delivery of
housing over the over the current and
last period are two separate things
so
that the point you made initially
regarding the five-year housing land
supply and housing delivery the two
aren't necessarily interconnected
because we've delivered the land we've
delivered those houses that
we've delivered the houses but the
problem is with the supply
of the the future housing
for us to hit that test in in future
years and that's what's been delayed by
um some of the
the lack basically the lack of
supply is because there's not been
enough houses
um approved through through planning
permissions some of those are delays to
those that are in the current plan for
exam example north haybridge um garden
settlement that was
when it came through initially as an
allocated site council rejected um the
application and there were subsequent
holdups so what it's done in effect is
push all of that housing back
from the schedule in which it should
have come forward which has meant we've
now got a gap
opening up
where where
we've delivered on schedule
those holdups in previous years have now
led to the supply being pushed back
causing the the um dip in the housing
supply but um i'll ask um
anal tough shoreline to come in as well
who can probably give some some more
planning detail on on that item thank
you
sorry can you hear me
yeah
um
[Music]
version of the five-year supply because
every time we publish and put all the
details out there in the public realm
that has to go into the planning reports
and then it changes every single week so
i monitor the five-year supply every
week
so in effect we could be publishing the
supply every single week it would be
different and it varies by those points
depending on how many planning
permissions you've granted and how many
houses you've
did you want to come back not really no
not really really because all due
respect we we know that but that's not
the point we were making if you if you
put in a risk putting this down in a
report it needs to be accurate or the
figures need to be able to be to be
backed up and taken on board what the
officers just just said
is is that if they were only doing it
once a year yes now we're monitoring it
but we're in a position now that we're
struggling because it wasn't monitored
she's an excellent officer we're not
talking about that we're talking about
what's happened and got us into this
state okay
well mr dodson screwing his face up
because he doesn't totally agree with me
we never agree on this so we better move
on to be fair because we don't agree on
it but i see it from a different point
of view and residents also see it from
the point of view don't produce a risk
to like this if you haven't got the
information to back it up that's all i'm
saying the officers might have it but we
don't know it but every one of us down
here around here is a little bit
confused by it thank you thank you
did you have any more questions
councillor stevens
i do please um but you'll be glad to
know that we can skip down to page 28
now please um
the table there with the top row which
is business satisfaction with malden
district council services via a survey
am i understanding this right were we
only wanting 30 of businesses to be
satisfied with our services is that
if i'm please somebody please tell me
i've misunderstood that thank you
mr thompson
misuse yeah so that that was the target
and that was based on an improvement on
the previous year
um
where we didn't receive particularly
high feedback so that's why that's the
target and obviously as uh
mr dalton mentioned
we will be doing a workshop to re-look
at when we reset these um
performance reports
and part of the reset of the performance
report is reviewing the targets that we
set
um
the same as what we did at the start of
this year
and so that would be the perfect
opportunity to um you know look at that
target and think about whether we want
to be more ambitious next year
thank you
councillor stevens i think that's just
one more on this section um page 36
please
it talks about the number of schools
supported by malden district council's
year six transition template
um
i'd appreciate some help in
understanding this one it says it's on
track but also that there have been no
further developments with the template
does that mean no children i think what
i'm getting to is does this mean that no
children have been helped please i think
i've asked this question before and i
think that this is because of the covid
and the fact that the schools were
closed um mr dobson
i'm
yes it was because those were delivered
as face-to-face
projects previously and they couldn't be
delivered
because of covid so though the activity
didn't happen
and so
will it happen
i mean we've still got quite a bit of
obviously the school year and our year
are different to each other is there
still room for it to happen
please thank you
i'll have to check on that detail thank
you
councillor fleming
thank you chair through you i'd just
like to ask um mr dodson a couple of
questions um first one is page 20
uh the air quality management um i just
wanted an update on that uh it says
target to
aqma action plan timetable
so i know that i'm a member of that
working group and it hasn't met for some
time
um i just wanted an update on on exactly
where the hold up was i seem to remember
there was a transport plan
um and just wondered whether that was
moving along thank you i'll hand chair
my hand to mr together
yes you're correct last time we met and
it was a long time ago there was a
request for a destination survey to be
done um where we we are aware that
destination survey's been completed
we're just waiting for it to be handed
across to us so we can double check it
um and then we can see how we we
reconvene the meeting and how we move
forward again
um one of the other things as well with
the air quality um action plan there was
a number of smaller targets that we were
hoping to achieve
and that's dependent on some grant
funding which we weren't successful for
last financial year we're actually
putting together a bid for this
financial year um we've brought some
help to try and get that bid together
so that should hopefully get everything
back on track
councillor fleming excellent thank you
um and my other question was on uh page
22
the um
where is that sorry
uh monitor of all section 106 agreements
and publish in the infrastructure
delivery statement um which i think
we've done we did at the end of the year
i think yep um
i was just wanted to ask whether
all ward members or division members
could be given um
a list of
the
the section 106 uh agreements for the
sort of strategic sites because i know
um
the strategic sites they were all passed
before our time so i mean certainly from
my perspective i would quite like to
know exactly what is in
the agreements for south malden garden
suburb for example um and i wondered
whether mr dawson that would be possible
thank you
yes that should be possible we have a
full list of of all of the the projects
that can be broken down and forwarded to
all members yeah would it be possible to
have that by monday
i i will need to hand over to to mrs
altoffshore to us ask that question i
need it particularly for what i'm eating
on tuesday thank you
when do you want it by monday because
after i knock off i won't be logging
back on until monday morning
by the end of the day thank you and
uh
yes please
all right is there any other question
councillor fluker thank you i mean there
was a time when that information on 106
agreements was reported to one of the
committees
it still is i'm told yeah so i would
have thought you'd better track it
through that anyway clearly nobody wants
to talk about what i want to talk about
because you've skipped over it also but
i i just like to drill in and
to page 21 and deliver a super fast
broadband i mean what this is saying
is that our target is to roll out
broadband to
offer the opportunity broadband to every
single dwelling in this district apart
from 300 that's impossible you cannot
deliver 99 coverage and the way this is
written
you know i can understand if it was 99
of what was being
offered by open reach but that's not
what this is saying
so
you know is it is this really saying now
that we can get within 300
dwellings in the district
i mean i we used there was a time when
you could see who owned the risk
and it's quite then easy to communicate
with the the officer to ask the question
in advance in the meeting through fresh
service
um not even a flicker from the directors
then when i mentioned fresh service
uh but yeah
i mean yeah if we're going to be able to
achieve this by the end of quarter four
i mean i'm well impressed but i can tell
you straight away there's over 300
houses
in in ashland and engine on the marshes
that you won't be able to reach and i i
i can see my friend
from burnham nodding over there so i
think we need to be careful with some of
these uh targets
mr dalson
yes we can get clarification of that
that target obviously the figure is for
for coverage not take up so it is the
ability for people to have it and and i
i understand that the the latest scheme
that they're introducing there are other
ways other than the open reach
um fibre cabinet through which are now
eligible for the the rollout of the
scheme but
i see clarification
to to be able to answer that in
detail if you could email that to the
members of this committee so that
everybody's got that answer please
um members if there's
no other questions
we will go back to the recommendations
that was little one members review the
information is set up in this report and
appendix one with priority focus given
to the strategic outcome level
performance and little two that members
confirm they are sure through this
review that corporate performance is
being managed effectively
is members in agreement of that
thank you
we move on to agenda item eight which is
the review of corporate risk quarter 3
page 41 to 52 miss hughes would you like
to present the report
so this report again covers the third
quarter of 21-22 which is september to
december 21 and the corporate risks
appendix one found on pages
43-51 of your agenda pack gives the full
table of the corporate risk register as
at the end of december 21.
section 3.1.1
of the covering report shows you where
the risks have changed directions since
quarter 2.
risk r13 failure to manage the impact of
organizational change is recommended for
closure as it relates specifically to
transformation work and is now replaced
with a specific new risk r31
resources and operating staffing
structure is not sufficient for
resilience
r14 unable to recruit and retain
specialist staff has increased in score
and r10 failure to develop jobs for the
population and r3 valued target services
and influence partners on the housing
needs of agent population have both seen
a decrease in likelihood
section
3.1.2 also cover emerging risks these
are areas where we think the school
could increase in the next quarter based
on the information we have at the time
members are asked to review the risk
register update and confirm assurance
through the update that corporate risk
is being monitored effectively
thank you
thank you miss hughes so the
recommendations are little one that the
members review the corporate risk
register in appendix one and approve
comment and feedback for consideration
little two that members are assured
through this review that corporate risk
is being managed effectively and little
three that members challenge risk where
the committee feels that the council's
corporate goals may not be achieved do i
have a second or for those
recommendations
councillor fleming
is there any questions for the officers
councillor stevens
thank you chair i'm looking at page 42.
i've just heard the explanation of
emerging risks because i was a bit
surprised to see covid on there as
emerging as though we've not kind of
heard of it before so i wonder if that
title emerging risks could be slightly
modified because it doesn't really
reflect
increasing risks i think might be a
better expression
and looking at this it says that one of
the risks is that we might be unable to
recruit and retain staff
i.e planners do i take that ie to mean
that this is only a problem in the
planning department or are there
problems in other teams as well please
thank you
mr dobson had his lat one but he's
turned it off
i was thank you chad i was going to ask
around the answer around the the
emerging risk
um
it was an emerging risk regarding covid
because this was at the end of um
quarter three that the report was
prepared at the time that we had omicron
emerging
and that we were expecting there to be
uh
or or there was a risk that there would
be a significant impact on services at
the time so whilst whilst it is worded
that it was linked to covid it was a
specific
emerging or growing risk at the time but
i take the point that it could be
increasing risk
equally as emerging
and the second part of your question
mr holmes thank you chairman um no that
was just an illustration that ie
planners we could say specialists and
that could include professional officers
such as housing environmental health as
well as planning
particularly planning and there's always
been a national issue with the shortage
of planners frankly um and it's been the
same for a number of years but um i
think across the services we're finding
it increasingly difficult to to attract
those specialists um to the council for
the various roles and we are carrying
vacancies as a result
thank you yes i think it's some just
worth dwelling on that a little bit
again coming back to whether this is an
emerging or an increasing risk
we haven't had a planning enforcement
for at least a year so i don't really
understand how this is emerging or just
increasing now because it's been there
all the time
um and we really don't seem to be
i can't see that we're doing anything
about it so we report it but i'd like i
suppose i'm looking for some action
around it but if the staff aren't there
i don't know what we can do but
um
it worries me that it's just appearing
as an emerging risk when it's been there
all year thank you
mr holmes i think probably yes perhaps
increasing risk then might be more
appropriate you're right there's always
been a background in there
i'd like to invite um perhaps hannah
wheatley my special service manager now
to perhaps illustrate some of the things
that she's doing and believe you me
we're not sitting back doing nothing and
we're working very very hard to actually
recruit people to the authority but i
think hannah might be able to furnish a
little bit of a background on that
yes i'm having to do that members
um
where we do have vacancies we try to
look at other options for covering those
vacancies by offering over time to
existing staff although generally their
workloads limit the amount of overtime
they can complete
we do also go to agencies to try and get
agency cover um but that is a very very
expensive option
for three months of agency cover you're
typically looking at about eight months
of permanent resource so that is a last
resort
in terms of training and development we
are looking at a pipeline to try and
bring our more junior members of
the team upwards um because
it does seem to be the more experienced
professionals where we have that
um challenge in terms of recruiting them
they tend to be attracted to the private
sector um there aren't many people going
into some of these very niche
specialisms so it certainly is an
increasing risk
thank you
are you do you need to come back on that
one councillor stevens no that's it
thank you okay miss councillor boyce you
put your hand up then i'll
nearly come right here again yes sorry
um uh i can't quote page or or number
um no i won't
um
but as a general question where in the
risk register is the
potential of increased homeless
homelessness sitting
thank you
mr geller
i'm afraid i don't have an answer where
in the risk register that that sits i'll
have to check on that part but it is
something that
you know we do monitor and we do report
on there's national reporting guidelines
for that
is there a specific query about the
homelessness data you want to try and
tease out or drill into
well where we are with rough sleepers
for instance as a as a simple thing uh i
mean reports say that there's an
increase in the molten district
okay
we do have that that data um
i can get that sent across to you
um there is a couple of specific cases
that i'm aware of that we're looking at
um and if you want details for those
cases i can arrange for those to be sent
across
i just thought it would be a corporate
risk um so if the question is
out of kilter with what we're on at the
moment i apologize chairman thank you
uh mr gillard if you do send that
information can you make sure you
include all the committees so that
everyone's aware of the answers
um councillor fluker you had your hand
thank you
a couple of things really because
it's all very well having a commentary
against the risks but we need to
understand what the mitigations are and
i think that's what councillor stevens
was alluding to but risks 14 and 31.
um
you know i would have liked to you know
you've identified the risks and there's
serious risks you haven't really sort of
come up with how you're going to
mitigate this other than identify the
problems but i mean i i would have liked
to have seen a narrative in there based
on what this miss wheatley just said
um you know the comparison between
hiring temporary staff against full-time
staff and the cost and that's
principally why we're not doing it as a
matter of course
and
also
i'd expect to see something in there
about shared servicing servicing and
outsourcing even if we can't do it it
means that we've identified it but
my other point was under risk five
um
i'd like to hear an update from
whoever's handling this risk five
regarding south minster medical center
a current update
and as far as risk five is concerned
since when have we been the highway
authority
because it appears that we seem to be
applying for
funding from the treasury for the south
northern relief road when we all know
that the reason why there's a shortfall
is because essex county council in their
capacity the highways authority
completely underestimated the cost of
the road
and that is absolutely critical to
delivering that site so
i'm sort of quite surprised to read that
in there what what what should be
written in there is is that we should be
telling essex county council to deliver
the relief vote they got the figure
wrong it's not our problem
you know the contractors probably
laughed all the way to the bank on this
one and you know we've had the story
they didn't do a topography a
topographical survey did a desktop
server and that's why they didn't
understand how the road went up and you
know we've had a big discussion about
this in the past but why are we applying
it for this grant and not estes county
council
and and the update on the medical center
i'd love to hear okay
uh mr holmes do you want to
chairman i i can do the first part and
then i had to mr dawson for the medical
center so in terms of in terms of your
observations around the mitigations i'm
sure um when we do that review of the
formatting then um ms hughes will be
picking that up but again like to
reassure members
issues such as shared services talking
to local other local authorities
happening right now so we are looking to
mitigate in a number of ways obviously
recruiting our team in is is probably
you know that i'm always on the list but
actually we are looking at uh
neighboring authorities to see where
they may have extra resources we already
have some uh shared service arrangements
we have them in licensing we have them
around emergency planning um we have
them in
a community safety so there are ways
that we're working quite successfully
and there are other areas where such as
planners
environmental health for instance we're
exploring those options so all things
are on the table um and we continue to
do that so i think when we come to look
at the format of the reports going
forward we could we could talk about
some of the mitigations as well in the
report for you
and i'll hand over mr dodson for the
other part
thank you
um south
south minister health center
i believe is
a weight in the full business case
within the nhs and
we ask this monthly
my latest understanding is that they're
in the midst of doing that business case
and as soon as it's completed they'll be
submitting the
um full planning application and i think
i've reported that to committee
previously and i've not had an update on
the the exact date of that when it will
come through but it will go through
their their full business case planning
process which is what they're preparing
at the moment
in terms of the south molden relief road
um
to some extent it's it's great but the
the
the county council highways would have
put forward the proposed costs of that
that were then agreed within the
inspection in public of the
um
ldp so it would have been embedded since
that time
there is a potential shortfall and we've
been working
hard with
essex highways and i think that's
demanding they deliver it
isn't necessarily going to make it be
delivered
we're working with them to ensure that
the
the funding that the design work is done
and the funding is found
and that they're looking to
to do that work on the design to try and
drive down the costs and also to look at
where additional funding can be
attracted from and we're also working
with the nhs around the the potential
for the site and whether there's any
further opportunities for contributions
towards that so we're working with the
landowners the highways and everyone
involved basically to see how we can
help remove the barriers to that road to
make sure that both the road is
infrastructure
and any associated development that that
will unlock can come forward as quickly
as
possible let me come back
so um south miss the medical center um
yeah
you didn't fall through the trap door
and i'm really pleased that you're doing
as much behind the scenes on that as i
am because i've been talking to mr
gillum regularly about this
and i know the developer oh i know the
landowner and it really does looks like
that's going ahead well so that's that's
good but
both
both directors have
said tonight chairman that we are under
a huge amount of pressure at the moment
we've got staff vacancies yet we appear
to be doing the work of essex county
council and delivering the road you know
i know how important that road is to us
but you know we do have to prioritize
things and and you sort of alluded to it
i mean there was a mistake made here and
it looks so
us as a council who we have to accept as
a snapshot we're totally under resourced
at the moment establishment wise and
we're we're doing the work first to scan
a council
you know
um it's it i don't want to sound spoiled
but it sounds terribly unfair
i i if i can come back on that you know
i think you know this is an area where
there is considerable effort going in
that potentially should have been an
issue that was resolved previously the
reason despite
our resource challenges that we're
putting so much effort into it is
because
we need to bring forward that
infrastructure for the the residents of
the district and that there's a knock-on
effect between that south mould and
relief road being delivered and
subsequently the the the modern health
hub and whilst we do have you know take
on board
but it's um a challenge for us with our
existing resources it's such an
important priority
that that we are making sure despite
those resources we're having those
discussions and really it's only through
partnership working rather than taking a
uh
going into a conflict around delivering
that that i think will be most
successful which is why it's the
approach that we've taken in working
with our partners to resolve those
issues however they came about in the
past
we've got the same position in my ward
with david fisher way
you know we've got we've got south that
we've got the uh
south minutes the
west relief road not opened
because of the shortcomings of essex
county council and and i i i just hope
that the two county members that are in
the chamber this evening take this back
to county
uh and hopefully come back to this
committee to say what's going to happen
i don't doubt they have
but then that then that you know i'd
like to think maybe well maybe
i'll give way to and you can tell me
what's happening i'm gonna say
councillor has kept on indicating she
wants to speak
um not breaching any confidence but i'm
actually going to back up
paul here um in the fact that when i was
the leader we did meet with the leader
of asic's county council
and we had a confidential meeting in
there and the essex relief road was
discussed at great length and
i actually commend mr dodson i
understand we've got resource issues and
some of that has come from the
transformation because of all the
changes and some of it's come because we
can't attract staff and one of the
things i wanted to say and i'm going to
combine these together with what council
fluke has asked me as well is are we are
we actually paying enough
have we looked at what the the packages
we're offering to try and get planners
yeah you can come back to me in a minute
i can see you you're champing at me at
the bit hang on a minute you've had your
say
um so i'd actually like to back up um mr
dodson um there's two separate issues
here the and and i also have pulled this
council about why the money wasn't put
in there because we knew the cost of
that relief word was going to
go um
to be honest off the scale
and i cannot believe that that wasn't
put in there for whatever reason however
many years ago that section 106 was
agreed um and i'm sure the world that
the division member it's you is is it
you jane who isn't it's not um counselor
um
mark forgotten his name durham um so you
know i think was world members and
division members we we have been doing
it and i'll give you an example even
tonight
okay i've had to write to the cabinet
member for highways because they don't
think that the road the old thorn road
is bad enough that's covered in potholes
and drains that collapse to be repaired
so if we're fighting against things like
that if this council doesn't work hard
to try and get essex county council to
move to build this relief road we're
going to become a car park you can just
say we're going to be like the m25 the
dungey and i'm not being flipping
because that's usually down to you you
crack the jokes but that is the way we
that is where we are what you do
that is where we are at the moment and
you can rest assured councillor fluke
and everybody else that the divisional
members for essex county council are
working very very hard indeed i'm i'm
going to go to councillor fleming
because she also had a question so
thank you i was just going to ask mr
dodson if he could um
just give an update written update to
the committee about the south malden
relief road
um
just a brief synopsis of where we are as
you see it
from molten district council the funding
gap how much that is exactly
um
and some
ways forward thank you
i mean based on that john i think it
would be useful for this committee
to be able to put some of these
questions to essex county council direct
this is a performance issue
uh it's a non-delivery of a very
important piece of infrastructure and
chairman i i would propose that uh an
officer for messages county council
highways is invited to this committee
we've done this before and it'll be
interested to see you know the
interaction between the division we'd
like enough to have the county members
here as well and it'll give us the
opportunity to ask them some questions i
i think the public need to know the
answer to these questions okay thank you
so i've made a proposal
do i have a second for that proposal
i'll support uh councillor fluker
because it is right and i know you
you're not you don't watch the um essex
county council full council meetings but
you'll most probably hear when some of
us actually raise questions uh and it's
generally always about highways and it
has like i've said rest assured we have
discussed it with the leader about
delivery of that relief road and we are
doing everything we can oh we were when
i was the leader and i'm sure that the
current leader um is is doing the same
and so is mr dodson because he said how
important it is and rest assured just
because you haven't had an update
doesn't mean to say it's not going on
behind the scenes i won't say behind
closed doors because you don't like
that's opening transparency but you know
exactly what i mean when i say that
because you were the leader and you had
conversations that couldn't be repeated
thank you councillor stamp is everybody
happy
with that proposal
yeah lovely thank you mr dobson can we
uh put that to essex county council and
invite them to this meeting or to the
next meeting thank you can i suggest
that we actually ask somebody with the
authority who can make and answer those
questions not a member of essex highways
but somebody who can actually make the
decisions i'll come to this council with
an update because otherwise it's a waste
of time
thank you i think jen fleming come back
i mean mr dodson must be dealing with
the the decision maker was close to it
so i think we'll leave it up to mr
dodson i was going to say mr dobson if
you can
organize that for us that'd be very
enough
is there any other questions council
fleming thank you thank you chair i just
wanted to go to uh mr holmes um i
understand we've recruited two new
enforcement officers is that correct and
i just wondered when they were going to
start and then i had a question for
hannah
weekly as well thank you
hannah will be able to answer both those
questions you're absolutely right we
haven't made the offers and she'll be
able to give you the detail
hello yes um in terms of the enforcement
officers yes we have appointed one into
the level 2 specialist role and also the
case worker role
we're just going through the onboarding
process so i am hopeful that the level 2
specialist will be joining us on the
first of april um i'm not too sure in
terms of the notice period for the
caseworker role but i'll be happy to
provide an update in respect to their
starting date or projected starting
thank you and again if you can send that
out to all members of the committee
hannah that'd be lovely thank you and i
just wanted to ask hannah when you um
advertise for staff where do you put
place of work is it in malden or would
you leave that sort of looser so that
you could recruit people nationally and
they could uh work digitally thank you
yes now that's a good question we did
update the job adverts
for prior to christmas so that we
explained that there is the opportunity
to work in an agile way but it does
state that our
office is based in malden and that
people can work from the office we are
going through a process at the moment
looking at job roles and the extent to
which they can be hybrid um but we've
just recently gone out to advert for a
senior role within the revenues and
benefits team um and because we have
been able to offer that as more of an
agile working option we've had some very
very strong candidates um so that is
very encouraging in terms of the fact
that by being able to offer that as an
option we are attracting good candidates
from across the uk
thank you
thank you hannah
thank you mr holmes you've
and perhaps just to illustrate the point
we were talking about sort of vacancies
obviously
members we we took a request for extra
funding to you back in the summer for
those enforcement roles it's taken this
long to find the right candidates and
that's certainly not before the want of
trying as i said we moved the goal post
several times to achieve that unemployed
please now we have so i think that
perhaps just demonstrates in certain
areas of the council we do have resource
issues and i know a number of members
are concerned about enforcement we're
still struggling to build that team up
so that's the sort of the back story but
you know it's it's an improvement
situation and we we certainly will be
you know making some attraction but that
just gives you a sort of an idea of the
world we live in in trying to recruit
and keep staff at the council thank you
mr holmes
council stamp
um yeah thank you um i think we've also
got to realize that the recent
reputation of this council may have
added to why certain staff maybe don't
want to come and work with us or for us
and
i think that's unfortunate because the
majority of members and officers nearly
all the officers i can't think of anyone
are actually excellent first class and
work so hard for this council but my my
point is uh r11 r11
failure to protect personal and
commercially sensitive data would that
risk in your view mr dodson or misuse
have changed slightly now would that be
downgraded if that's not too politically
insensitive
this was a risk assessment at the end of
of quarter three there have been
changes since then that would have
significantly reduced the risk of the
council yet i think it's really
important that we as members do make
sure that we do follow and we don't
breach confidentiality because that has
obviously gone into the information
commission commissioners offices
officers do we get sanctions could i ask
through you chair have we been
sanctioned or just a note or something
goes on the web on their page
i understand today we haven't been
sanctioned but we have had to report
ourselves
to the um data commissioner
um when there have been breaches
but but to date those breaches haven't
been significant enough that we've
received a final or sent you as far as
i'm aware but
mr leslie may have no no that's
absolutely right we reported um the ico
information commissioner obviously will
review it um of course uh they are
they have the ability to
fine
people for breaches but that has not
happened to date
thank you
councillor seancey
yes thank you chair i was going to bring
up this same point as council stamp just
has um and i
and i believe i read on page 54 that
there is some training
for members um
on this thank you chairman thank you
all right members are there any other
questions council stevens
thank you chair on page 51 um risk one
actually it is about it says failure to
safeguard children and vulnerable adults
i'm very pleased to see that the overall
risk rating is reducing we now only have
a likelihood of one which is good
but given the importance of safeguarding
can i just seek assurance that this
really definitely is now a likelihood of
only one i'd like to know what are the
outstanding contractor management and
support improvements that are referred
to please and where is the separate
audit actions is mentioned here because
i couldn't see it in here maybe i'm
looking for the wrong thing thank you mr
geller
thank you so in terms of the
safeguarding meetings yes they're all
taking place
um
they're functioning well
in terms of the
list of contractors and
their
their um
safeguarding requirements that those
checks are being done it's just where we
hold those centrally and and so they're
all coordinated in one place that work
still needs to happen
um and in terms of the other audit
points
um
that
they're all contained
that they're all being dealt with
they're all contained separately
so i'll have to go away and just check
when you say the other audit points um
so the very end of the commentary on
that item says however this should have
minimal bearing on risk and is contained
within a separate audit action and i
just wondered where that is please i
think that when we had the audit report
last 18 years there was a um
a risk around
forms
for safeguarding
yes yes
my apologies yes the the safeguarding
audit did contain a list of
recommendations
um so they had additional points that we
needed to hit uh the main one was um
in relation to starting up the meetings
again the other one was regarding the
the contractors list which which i
referenced then the other one was to do
with forms and access to forms uh forms
and access to forms has been sorted out
um
we had paper copies we still have those
there's also an electronic
version that that staff and
others can access to input data on and
to raise risks
thank you thank you
is that all councillor students
thank you yes i'm on page 57 have i gone
too far or yeah you've gone on
okay
right thank you members
we had the recommendations little one
that members review the corporate risk
registry and appendix one and
provide comment and feedback
consideration which i think you've all
done the little two the members are sure
through this review that corporate risk
is
and is being managed effectively
and little three the members challenge
where the committee feels that the
council's corporate goals may not be
achieved
are you all happy to agree those
recommendations council stamp don't we
have council of lucas
um edition on here oh yes sorry
yes your your additional proposal if you
would like to just
go through that again
okay and that was seconded
yeah
and that was seconded by councillor
stamp and that was agreed do you have
that burner
yes
okay thank you
moving on to
item nine on the agenda the balanced
scorecard exceptions report pages 53-56
uh miss hughes would you like to present
that report
yes
um so the report details areas of
operational performance where we are
seeing exceptions which covers both
under and over performance
internally the leadership team monitor
this data and discuss it monthly to help
address performance issues in real time
where possible
and a six monthly report is then
provided to the committee to show
exceptions
this report covers july
3.5 of the report provides a table of
measures that are underperforming with
an explanation of action that is taking
place to address each one
3.5 3.5.1 also highlights an emerging
trend that we're seeing but where the
data is currently within tolerance this
is around an increase in housing demand
the team are currently managing this
operationally
[Music]
that operational performance is being
managed effectively thank you
thank you miss hughes so recommendations
little one the committee review and
comment on the exceptions to service
reporting provided in the report and
little two that members confirm they are
assured through this review operational
performance is being managed effectively
can i have a second of those
recommendations
councillor fleming thank you
is there any questions
councillor
thank you chair page 57 um summary of
key issues where we've got some
accidents and the near miss this one
with the dog a member of staff that's
that's the next oh sorry that's the next
one yeah you're still you're still too
early
[Music]
i'll keep quiet again
we are on pages um
i just lost it
[Laughter]
yeah 53 to 56 so is there any questions
on those pages
no
okay thank you
so are you all happy to accept those
recommendations
thank you
item 10 on the agenda is the review of
health and safety quarter 3 pages 57
57-72
mr holmes this is your
thank you chairman yes i'd like to just
briefly go through the report and then
we'll help you with any questions so uh
you'll see there were five accidents of
one you missed during this particular
quarter as you see the four formatters
remains changed so we now talk about the
incident and the action any detail that
sits behind them so they're all laid out
for members and obviously happy to
answer your questions as we go through
the reporter at the end um the
unacceptable behavior incidents were
also reported in the section 3.2 of the
report
section 3.3 of the report looks at the
health and safety action plan and you'll
see that set out at appendix 1.
there are a number of activities that
have happened within that report and
also like to draw your attention to 3.4
we've now had a third party engaged
trying to take fire risk assessments for
the council all of its buildings
including those that are leased out to
third parties and this work started at
the end of last year and will complete
during this year itself um the reports
themselves are set out to check on all
of the necessary requirements are in
place and we'll make any recommendations
for improvements we also will work with
the tenants and the people occupying the
buildings to bring those buildings to
set a satisfactory standard so that's an
important and piece of work that's
underway
um we've also picked up health and
safety risk assessment training
and we've now identified a number of
managers also requiring that training
and that work is also scheduled for this
year
all areas of the council uh covered by
this work um and obviously including
specifically around our service delivery
and parks and planning
um health and safety policy uh remains
unchanged but it's just been updated uh
to uh reflect on your organizational
structure and that's set out for you in
appendix 2.
um the bulk of the report straddles q3
and q4 activity and i think it's
important that we we talk about work
that's happening now into
q4 and we'll update a little bit further
um on you at the end of q4 but i thought
it was important so you could see the
work that's underway um and thanks to
colleagues uh they're on the on the
team's call this night that's sue green
hannah wheatley and farley norman this
has really taken
a a a great deal as a step forward
really and taking these actions so
you'll see under 372 a number of
activities that are underway and we've
now set up an internal health and safety
working group and that's made up of
officers from across the authority and
who monitor health and safety
in in the authority
and we've set up a new information
sharing system under sharepoint it's a
system that we have in the council and
that will be the reference point for all
of our records going forward and that
brings together a number of um areas
that we're keeping separate records so
we will now get a single picture which
is as much improved
um
we're also uh upgrading our arrangement
about fire and emergency arrangements
we're looking at our own depots in
prince's road and making any relevant
changes in the same way we're looking at
our properties that are actually leased
out
health and safety inspections are also
under been undertaken um across all
areas of the council and all partners
areas so we mentioned a little bit
earlier and we're also doing a lot of
work around kosh
we're also picking up activities under
the smart objectives for staff to make
sure they have health and safety
included where relevant into their
particular roles
we've
also identified um a reporting system
for accidents and near misses so you may
well see more reports of near misses
coming through because we've now got a
proper reporting system and actually
training the staff on what are near
misses um and that will you will see an
increase in reports coming forward
that's a summary of what we've been
doing between 3 qm and q4 but into
quarter 4 we're also looking at a number
of specific other actions and they're
detailed under 3.9 of the report so be
happy to help with any questions tonight
members thank you mr holmes
recommendations is little one that
members consider the accident and
incident statistics little too that
members consider progress and help with
the health and safety action plan and
little three that members consider
additional health and safety
improvements can i have a secondar
councillor fleming councillor stevens do
you want to ask your question
thank you am i definitely at the right
time
sorry
um yeah so page 57 we've got these
accidents and a near-miss the first
accident listed there is that a housing
officer was bitten by a dog whilst
visiting a member of the public in their
home
well first of all i hope that the staff
member concerned is fully recovered
because it must have been really very
shocking
um
i don't feel the responsibility and onus
lies entirely with the staff though
so yes we have an action that's sort of
empowering staff to request for a dog to
be secured
but the member of the public has a huge
responsibility here
and i kind of get that we can't put
their responsibility down as i will
we've issued that responsibility
but we should have something here around
writing to
somebody or being able to
how do we almost contract with the
person that they do secure their dog
before one of our staff goes into their
home
thank you
mr geller i can see your thank you um
firstly in relation to
whether we can ask someone to to secure
a dog yes there's certainly something we
can we can work into that so my
recollection about this particular case
though was uh it was in relation to uh
um a housing visit to a vulnerable
person they had i think the dog was a
small to medium-sized dog got quite
excited and that resulted in a nip
when it comes to
visiting officers in terms of the forms
that they know when they're going to the
property what they're going to expect
i'm pretty sure that form doesn't
actually state
whether a pet is present or not so we
can certainly work that in and
try and prevent against this happening
again
thank you thank you council stamp
yes thank you madam chair i've actually
put in big letters well done i'm
absolutely impressed with this it's
something that they've worked hard on um
there's a new member of stuff i don't
like really singling members of staff
out but um mr holmes did mention
somebody as a new member of the team and
he has worked very hard and keeps
members informed ward members of things
that are going on
and i think it's really good because
this is something i really pushed for
um because i thought it really needed
looking into quite seriously and i'd i'd
like to say thank you and well done and
i think it's a document that's a live
document that will keep evolving um so
you know housing officer was bitten by a
dog yes so it was it's really
unfortunate that we all go into dogs and
we think you know you're lovely lovely
and we can get a little nip somewhere so
sometimes we we're a little bit too
friendly maybe ourselves but um yeah
once again i'd like so well done to the
team um for everybody who's worked hard
on this it's something we needed to do
and i think they've delivered it thank
you thank you
is there any other questions councillor
stevens
sorry thank you chair um same table at
the top of page 58 we've got this one
with the chair that failed and we've got
an action that the chair was disposed of
and so was another chair
but not the chairman of course
um i just think yeah but we ought to be
having a rolling look at our furniture
if there's chairs around that are
falling apart then another one will go
next year so can we have a further
action in there to be
looking ahead a bit
and stopping this from happening before
it does thank you
i did ask these questions mr holmes in
the agenda meeting um
so he should have an answer to her
mr holmes
short answer is yes
so
yes you're absolutely right we do need
to do inspections on equipment i've got
to check whether the caretakers do a
rolling inspection of chairs whether
there was a a fracture or it was a
simple break i don't know but you're
absolutely right so we'll we'll capture
an extraction to make sure there's a
maintenance check on those
mr holmes can we also ask whether the
there was a misuse of the chair i was
the person standing on the chair or was
the because we seemed to be of different
opinions when we read that
last time
indeed i'm not sure of the circumstance
that happened but clearly and he hasn't
happened and the chair collapsed so we
need to uh understand what why that
happened but yeah yeah we would check
them in any case thank you
is there any other questions for mr
holmes mr fluke uh counselor so
i mean this is quite interesting because
the way i've read this this happened in
the reception area which is currently
being released by national health
services yeah so one presumes that
within the terms of that lease
we are responsible for the fixtures and
fittings now bear in mind the amount of
use that place has had but i mean what
concerns me about this is if you read
the report typically it talks about
health and safety and it's all being
responsible for it and it talks about us
being
proactive rather than reactive
now
some of you will remember um when
councillor richard dueck
uh uh collapsed through a chair uh in
the training room and subsequently
successfully sued this council
now our insurance company settled with
him
uh and quite rightly so
yeah so i hope
now that i've jogged mr holmes's memory
about that
uh we really will be proactive and
because these quite these chairs are all
a bit wobbly and what have you and
we live in a very legacious society
uh and we should learn we should learn
from
councillor durex bad luck but
nevertheless success
and i think we have learned and i'll
invite if you may uh sue green to make a
comment around that particularly this
incident that she's got a bit more
information probably helped with the
bigger picture okay this green
and it wasn't something that was visible
um and after the incident happened every
single chair
was then fully checked and there was one
other that was showing signs of
potential um issues so that was removed
and destroyed and when we do have
regular checks that are undertaken um
[Music]
and there wasn't it wasn't any misuse if
it was just
um one of those things unfortunately i
believe it's a soldier that had cracked
underneath one of the chairs and not
something that was very visible
thank you
is there any other questions for
mr councillor morgan thank you madam
chairman i'm just wondering are those
members of staff who habitually use
uh computer screens offered free eye
tests
chairman yes the as part of our package
for staff we do offer that so sort of
the display screens and all of those are
sort of looked at through our health and
safety processes as well so yes we do
offer those services
thank you
council stamp yeah i think you'll
remember because i asked if it was
extended to members because i've
struggled a lot with screens and it's
not is it
no
thank you
is there any other questions from mr
holmes
now members are you happy to accept
those recommendations thank you
item 11 on the agenda is the annual
governance statement action update
quarter three pages 73-78
miss hughes would you like to present
um so as part of the new annual
governance statement format we identify
actions that are around continual
improvement to our governance
arrangements and best practice
the report found on page 73 of the
agenda pack gives an update for the
actions identified in the 2021
report
there's a summary table set out in
section 3.5 of the report with officer
commentary
actions that have been highlighted in
grey have previously been reported to
this committee as completed but in
addition to this there is a new action
reported as close
and two which are ongoing
we are currently drafting the 21-22
annual governance statement and any
outstanding actions will then be
reflected in this as well as new actions
around the latest best practice thank
you thank you
recommendation that the committee
reviews the annual government statement
table and updates below and challenges
where necessary do i have a secondar
thank you councillor fleming are there
any questions for the officers
councillor stamp only one i brought up
yes before yesterday's meeting um
are we getting the owl equipment mr
dodson
is it called the owl the roving owl eye
or something so when we have remote
meetings people can actually see
you know the hybrid meetings rather than
you know somebody's already messaged me
they can't see our lovely two
councillors sitting on the end there
today
somebody said were you here and i said i
could hear them um but yeah so are we
upgrading our systems please
there's a camera sitting over there
that isn't connected yet that will do
exactly
what you've just suggested so yes
okay lovely thank you and we will note
that the camera's sitting over there
is there any other questions
no our members happy to accept those
recommendations thank you
item 12 on the agenda is any other item
of business that the chairman of the
committee decides is urgent there are
none
therefore i will close this meeting at
five past
nine
thank you members thank you for your
contributions this evening i now draw
the meeting to a close
the big
you